which brings me now to what's going on
in kenosha so i'll just quickly go over
this
uh the the uh the news here washington
post reports
after video shows wisconsin police
shooting a black man multiple times
national guard called into kenosha i'm
sure most of you have heard the story
already
it's about a man named jacob blake he
rounds the front of a silver suv on
sunday
with two kenosha wisconsin police
officers falling close behind their guns
drawn
when blake opens the door and steps
inside the officers suddenly fire into
his back at least seven times
he's currently in serious condition the
officers have been placed on
administrative leave
and the city of kenosha declared
declared emergency curfews
after protests rocked the city into
early monday morning
another curfew was set for monday night
while the governor announced he had
called
in the national guard so the video goes
viral i think calling in the national
guard was the right thing to do i agree
especially after the george floyd riots
got as crazy as they did yeah
but a lot of people right now it's it's
really coming down on partisan lines
on the left they're like how could the
police shoot a guy seven times in the
back
on the right they're saying he was
clearly resisting officer's orders he
reached into a vehicle
the cops are justified so i'll just jump
to it what's you know
you're you're a republican you're in a
very blue district
and i'm but you've also grown up and
it's the you grew up in the fourth ward
which is
i'll let you describe it because the
fourth ward is good fun bring your
bring your family and kids that's a
great place to be i think
but um no fourth ward is uh it's it's
not
put it like this it's it's always been a
pretty dangerous place as a child
growing up um even though it was
dangerous we didn't have the amount of
shootings that we have today now it's
like literally if you have the news
break app on your phone
literally every other day sometimes
every single day someone's getting shot
so here's here's what i'm thinking you
know i'm really clear uh curious as to
your opinion
on on defunding the police you know
specifically on what these cops did with
this guy
so so apparently there's a man of the
same name who lived on that block
because i'm because we don't know if
exactly it's him i'm assuming it is
but he's got uh he had an open warrant
for third degree
felony sexual assault there's there's
also a new circulating that at one point
he hadn't he
was arrested for illegally having a
concealed firearm or something that
effect
i'm wondering if the cops took that
information when they were going in and
said hey there's this guy or whether
they knew or they didn't
but i'm curious your thoughts on this
situation and defunding the police
considering
you you you know you live in an area
which is 35 minutes outside of new york
you're running as a republican
and you're in an area that's i guess not
too great
yeah so what do you what do you think so
so to touch on to touch on uh the
situation that happened in minneapolis
um when i saw the video at first
the first thing i said is listen we
don't we don't have all the facts and
even what you're telling me right now
that this guy could have possibly
you know had warrants existing or
whatever i don't know that so i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna completely double down and
say that this guy was in the wrong or
whatever what i will say is this
the shooting seven times is absolutely
unnecessary i think that was a little
bit excessive
now another thing i will say though is
regardless of what stance you are in a
situation where anybody not just a
police officer has a gun aimed at you
you don't turn your back on somebody
with a gun
aimed at you um and from the way that it
looked in the video he was trying to get
in the car some people say he was
getting in the car some people said he
was reaching for something
the only thing that i'm focused on is
when you got to the car your hands are
not
they're not visible right you're opening
it to a vehicle that they don't know
what's inside that vehicle right
now maybe these police officers weren't
trained effectively i don't know what
the situation was
but you shot this guy up right maybe he
had a gun maybe he didn't have a gun
right we don't have the facts on that
the problem that i have though is when
people emotionally jump to something and
start burning down the city like we have
like we've got going on right now i
firmly believe
that the only way to fix this problem is
to reform the police
now you see what happened in new york
they cut back i believe was 1.7 billion
from the budget
cut about 1.7 billion off of the budget
they they closed off the uh the crime
task force in new york and crime shot up
almost 200 plus percent
now a lot of people are leaving new york
people are even leaving and moving into
my city of all
i don't know why but you're moving into
my city of all places um
and they're bringing in a lot of that
violence as well too a lot of the people
believe that we got to get rid of the
police and patterson for example about
two days ago and i
like i told you i got the video up on my
website where i went up and i spoke with
some of these black lives matter
protesters kind of just
you know picked their brain to what's on
their mind because they painted this
mural in the middle of the street
and when i started speaking with them a
lot of them had the mentality of well
we need to done we needed to fund the
police and get rid of the police and i
say okay
so i'm gonna play devil's advocate here
if we defund the police
then what what's the solution because
new york isn't defunded
they just cut the budget and you already
see the ramifications of that if you're
talking about a complete total defunding
of these police
what's the solution what do you replace
it with right are we gonna rebuild the
community task force
that's gonna take some time and we ain't
got time right so
the only solution that i see in places
there has to be a way to clean up the
police
from within right when george floyd
passed away was this was the time when i
announced what i what i created it's
called the jarrow bill stands for
justice accountability and reporting
officers bill right
and this is an idea that i had shortly
after the time that eric gardner got
killed but i had no aspirations for
running for congress or anything at that
point i just figured
now would be a great time to talk about
it and what i feel is
when something happens in a in an
internal
investigation right and in this case uh
i brought up to these these uh
these young individuals with black lives
matter i brought up a case that happened
to a guy named jamik lowry
in patterson new jersey now this
gentleman
he um he walked into a police department
he was on a live stream some people say
he was on drugs some people say it
wasn't that's besides the point
but he gets on the camera and he starts
talking about how he's afraid someone's
after him and they're going to kill him
or whatever
long story short he leaves in an
ambulance the following day his face is
swollen shut and he's dead
there's still no proper answer so what
happened the patterson police department
they did an investigation to try and
see what happened internal investigation
said no wrong doing we did nothing wrong
we investigated ourselves and found we
did nothing wrong exactly my point so
you so you raise
you you raise the biggest issue in this
problem right because
when this happened i told him i said if
i asked him he's like do you really
believe that that the paterson
administration or even
the administration of the state of new
jersey cares about uh black lives
and he said no i don't believe they do
and i say well they didn't give us any
justice or any solid answers for what
happened to jamik lowry
yet they're allowing you to paint a
massive black lives matter
logo in the middle of the street dude
this is a virtue signal yeah
this is not action this is not progress
you know it's a symbol in the sense that
hey you know they're listening to us but
they're listening to you to paint in the
street they're not answering the actual
questions
bread in circuses that's exactly what it
is throwing out bread the crowd cheers
and that's it they forget about it yeah
you know so then i said listen what
needs to be done to to fix the situation
is we have to find
out when we need to create an
organization that can police the police
because if the police are policing us
who police is them right who watches the
watchmen
so the way that i feel that something
like this would get resolved is there
needs to be a new elected
class we have free holders well
something else now because governor
murphy
said it's whatever he's going to call it
you know freeholder mayor councilman all
this stuff
there needs to be something else called
in this case i call like the community
justice officer right this is the person
who
say a situation like jameek lowry
happens right they go to this person hey
listen we need you to help us
investigate the situation we can't
really count on the police to give us
a thorough investigation now there's two
things that are wrong with that problem
is what if that person gets corrupted
by the local police departments right
okay cool so that brings two parts or
what if the police aren't cooperating
with this person right
the next phase is the federal government
the department of justice i believe
needs to create a national police
department
right interesting because we've already
got the fbi the fbi gets involved in
some of these cases only when it's very
high profile you know massive drug deals
or or uh or george floyd situation where
it's a nationwide kind of thing that's
the only time to get involved
so i believe that the department of
justice needs to create these this
national police force
their job solely is to investigate the
police officers right
have the same the same ability to get
into the information check out the
evidence just like the fbi can
right now they can also prosecute these
police officers if they find something
wrong
the reason why i believe this has to
come from a federal level is because one
they have no allegiance
to the state police they have no
allegiance to the municipal police as
well too right
their job is solely to get to the bottom
of the problem and prosecute
now with uh with a situation like this
the next question someone asked is like
well
what if the fbi i mean what if the
department of justice gets corrupted
right let's say
there's a guy in new jersey who's
working there i wouldn't want that i
would want an officer from montana
to go and investigate what's going on in
new jersey or something like something
to that effect
second phase of that is i also believe
that police officers need to go through
more routine training they typically go
through six months of uh
six months in in police academy every
now and then they
you know brush up on their firearm
skills brush up on cpr and that's about
it
but if you're a doctor dentist or any
one of these these really high profile
jobs you have to renew your license
periodically being a police officer is a
very complicated
position right you got to you got to do
all kinds of stuff deal with mental
health deal with
you know de-escalation all kinds of
things like that so i believe that
at least twice a year once or twice a
year these police officers would have to
go through this training all over again
and i believe there should be an
incentive for it as well too right
if you go to a class that teaches you
how to disarm a gun or whatever the case
may be right i believe that police
officers should be
compensated for that they should be they
should be given um preferential
treatment for doing these kinds of
things
the reason why i say this is because if
these justice officers come
and they do an investigation they can go
down the list okay officer brown did
this this this and this well then why
did you mess up
how did you mess up the next problem
we've got going on here is the unions
it's very difficult to get rid of the
unions and i have no intention of
getting rid of the unions they're there
for a very specific reason and i
understand that
the problem i have with the unions is
they're going to protect the police to
make sure that they look as good as
possible so that they can continue to
get the funding so that the police can
continue to pay the unions and
keep their existence together right and
for these reasons there's some good
officers and i've spoken with lots of
them and told them the same idea
they agree with me you know there's lots
of very good officers that want to do
the right thing but
it's very difficult to do the right
thing when the union controls what's
going on you try and go against the
grain and they can
make your life very very difficult you
know um
so if they're not going to rat or snitch
on each other or throw each other under
the bus
my solution is this as a police officer
if your job is to uphold the law you
should be held to a higher standard
if you do something as wrong as stealing
two pennies from somebody and we find
out
you're doing 15 years 15 15 years
the cop you say yes the cop the reason
why i say this because
how how can you enforce the law
and you're not able you're not willing
to accept the full punishment for you
violating the law you're supposed to
uphold in the first place
right but you're are you being are you
exaggerating in 15 years like you're
just saying like you commit a crime you
do the time
correct essentially and now it's like we
don't now of course we have to work out
the legalities here
of whether this will make sense or not
but the point that i'm making is like if
we find out that you've done something
wrong you have to face the penalties for
it absolutely you have to
you can't because like it's too often
where you know a police officer does
something ridiculous and they kind of
just walk off
like a slap on the wrist administrative
leave or whatever the case may be and
you shouldn't have situations like that
i got a guy off in uh uh
i shouldn't say i shouldn't say it that
way i got a guy uh
found innocent get that one clipped
everybody
he was uh filming on the sidewalk cop
came up and arrested him
lied on the arrest report that the dude
was obstructing a street
right and i had footage of it so my
footage got the guy
uh proven not guilty put it that way
everybody
but uh the officer nothing ever happened
you see so this lady got to lie
under oath to get someone arrested and
we had video evidence that she lied
nothing happened of course that's that's
too much for me exactly and it's like
situations like that happen all the time
and that's just
that's just a small situation right so
now if something like that happens now
let's say
they're investigating officer brown the
chief knows the union knows everybody
knows that this guy messed up
right he didn't follow his training he
did whatever the case may be you're
trying to protect that guy
now you're obstructing their
investigation you go down with him as
well
it's tough though like you look at what
happened in kenosha and
when you look at it without any context
you can i can frame the story of kenosha
this one way
a guy was walking to his car after
breaking up a fight
the police officers then decided to stop
him
because he was refusing their orders and
fired seven times in the back it was
excessive
man this guy this is what the left is
saying he was just trying to break up a
fight he was doing the right thing his
kids were there
that's one way to frame it i could frame
it another way a
wanted rapist was trying to flee from
the police
and reached into his vehicle it's a very
different you know very different way of
looking at it
right of course the left because it
empowers their their ideology and
their narrative will go with the you
know oh no this poor man
and you know there are many
conservatives who are saying well he
reached in the event it was justifiable
i think the truth is a little closer to
the middle right you shouldn't look the
cops are you know trying to stop you he
was trying to flee
but you look at this and you have to you
wonder about whether cop the cops here
should face you know some kind of
penalty if they
entered this and they were told as
they're driving in
we have a man who has an open warrant
for
felony sexual assault possibly armed
past conviction for illegal concealed
weapon
be advised and then the cops pull up
thinking like this guy
is not only a violent abuser of women
but he could have a gun
and he's ignoring us and he reaches in
the vehicle did those cops do anything
wrong
if that's how they were you know told to
go in it it's
you know when i see uh stories like this
and
and many other stories it sounds like
the real issue like brianna taylor for
instance
the issue is the system right the system
has has flaws
and we need to set it up in a way to
maximize
like the the the protection of
individuals everybody minimize the loss
of life
i was you you i'm sure you read about
the brianna taylor stuff yes yes i was
reading about it
and it's it's really difficult they're
saying arrest the officers
and i'm like i don't like the idea of
plain clothes no knock raids
but it seems like that was the problem
they were told to go do this and they're
like okay
and that's why i was like dude it was
awesome that you were like i'm not gonna
do something i think is wrong
these cops should be like i'm not
kicking someone's door in and playing
clothes you know so for example a
situation like that makes perfect
example it makes perfect sense let's say
a police officer says hey i'm not going
to do something i feel it's illegal
whatever right this police officer
should have the ability to go and speak
to these officers in the department of
justice listen they're trying to tell me
to do something illegal
regardless of what the union tries to
say or do it's like when the
investigation really comes down to it
and they could find out that these
police officers
were giving you an unlawful order then
you're clear because even what's going
to happen here in kenosha they're going
to do an investigation like you said
there's some people on the right that
are like well you know you reach into
his car et cetera et cetera people on
the left say whatever whatever right
no matter what answer no matter what
answer that the
the police department puts out no one's
gonna care
you know people are gonna try and burn
down the city and do whatever the hell
they want
primarily because it's like oh well the
police killed him
they allowed it to happen and now
they're saying it's all good they're
going to burn the city down
right right so this is the reason why i
believe
there needs to be a third party a third
party that's completely unbiased that
has nothing to do and has no allegiance
and
could care less whether you're in the
right or wrong they just need to get to
the bottom of it
right i believe that's the only that's
that's the only logical solution to this
because
um until we can come up with something
or if there ever will be and i highly
doubt there will be
a solution where it's a community-based
police force where it's just as
organized as the police force as we have
today
um this is what we have and with the
situ when we have a system like this in
place
the police are left with three options
if there's a scumbag police officer
on on the force you got three options
either stop what you're doing or do the
right thing
you quit or eventually you get caught
and when you get caught you're going to
prison
those are only three options this isn't
going to hurt the unions at the end of
the day you want to protect your guys i
get that it's in your best interest to
have the best police officers on the
force
period right so if this is if you i get
you guys want to protect them but
the more you have better police officers
on your force that are better trained
that are routinely getting trained
there's no excuses for them to go out
there and do nonsense like this
everything you're saying is the opposite
of defund the police well yeah of course
because it's like defunding it's not
going to work
it's not going to work more training
more resources so
of course it's going to it's going to
require because i'm a big advocate of
increasing the funding for police people
saying whoa increasing
how are you expecting to get this
training trump saying the same thing
right how do you expect how do you
expect to hold them accountable
you know because like when you start
wearing thin their resources like i had
a conversation with my friend
the other night and he would say like
you know if something like this happened
in patterson man like what would happen
if there was a riot what are we gonna do
and i'm like in all honesty man
a patterson i believe they have about
two or three of these armored vehicles
right for
these these raids for you know drug
dealers whatever the case may be
they probably got about three or four of
them they don't have the power to do a
massive um full-scale operation just
going crack down on everybody
overnight this is just my opinion what i
believe and even if something like that
were to happen
they'd be they'd be stretched really
thin for resources if a riot ever took
place in patterson they'd have to call
in the national guard
yeah right they'd have to so what it
would a lot what a lot of people need to
understand is like the police
they're humans just like us you know
they don't have
the they're not as powerful as we really
think they are
and the more we try and chip at them and
try and decrease their funds and try and
make life difficult for them you're
making life difficult for everybody
across the board
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you